[Applause]
um on the album dude you have
you know the record that really hit me
was the depression record which i
thought
uh melodically is an incredible song but
just the content of the record i feel
like
you know not a lot of people deal with
um their depression
openly and it's a it's kind of like a
subject that doesn't get a lot of uh
that probably doesn't get as much
coverage as it is because i think a lot
of people sometimes are ashamed that
they feel like they're depressed or
they're in a dark place and then we find
out someone dies because they overdose
or they kill themselves or some [ __ ]
i mean look like to hear a song from a
16 16 17 year old kid about depression
is crazy because my sis my son's 14 in
the in the next room like
um talk about your battle with
depression like you know what i'm saying
like
and and how serious that was and like
you know why you why
you choose to be open with it with the
world it's like
i don't know i feel like ain't none you
used to be a shy anthony
cause it actually helps in a certain way
because like people know that
you know they perceive me as a hype
[ __ ] i don't be hype like that i'd be
cool
but in your videos you'd be hype as [ __ ]
yeah i'd be hyped in my videos
it's like a switch it's like a switch
you're like yeah i just be cooling but
i don't know that was something i always
do with depression like because i was
always
different i just was always different
like i said i always wanted
you went this way i wanted to go that
way like i didn't want to just
you know and [ __ ] this [ __ ] just
it made it hard for a lot of people to
get along with me for me to keep
[ __ ] going with people because i was
just always different as [ __ ] nobody
knew how to adapt to me so
[ __ ] started [ __ ] would hate on me so
i had to you know it was just a lot of
[ __ ]
and a lot of problems since i was
younger today here but
when i got when i said i dropped my
album i lost myself doing my
albums like [ __ ] i lost myself making my
own but then when i dropped it i said i
found myself again because that's around
the time
i started meditating and like when you
put it in your mind that you don't have
it
like that you don't have a prisoner you
don't have anxiety
like you keep saying it in your head
like it gets worse probably
no it gets better it does get better
okay you it's like when you
you know you cool you don't have you
just be like
was that white cause it's like because
your brain gonna tell you what yo
it's your brain to see your whole
reality it's gonna if you
that's how i was i was like man i'm the
prison citizen you know
that's how i'm feeling but if i just
changed my thought looked at all the
positive and kept thinking about the
positive yo
much were you in like because i do feel
like you had a few episodes where you
were on ig live that were kind of wild
like was that like you
yeah you had some crazy ig live episodes
i was like yo what the hell
i used to be tweaking someone get this
man was that was that because of
depression or was it because of drugs or
like what were you going through at
those times because you had some wild
[ __ ] going on man
i don't know because like and then i me
that's what you know when i talked to
you i was like yo man like
you got this bro like you know what i'm
saying like and then okay like you're
obviously a smart kid you have your head
on straight
but there was some times where like you
you were at some low points and the
whole world saw
yeah i was mad at here i'll just be mad
a little mad ass
look sad ass [ __ ] man but cool now
[ __ ] i'm gonna do that [ __ ] be cool of
mind trying to see better
days i got a daughter so much more i can
look forward to yes sir